andreas hindbo prices up what's likely
to be one of the last
shipments of mink pelts to leave the
farm his father started nearly 40 years
ago
the rest of their herds are among the
millions of minks that the danish
government ordered to be slaughtered
after a mutation of covid 19 was found
in the animals
it could mean the country's mink
industry the largest in the world
disappears altogether
mink farming is a lifestyle they made in
march you get kids in april then you
watch them grow
and get this beautiful fur here that's
hard for me to live without
but i'll have to learn farmers began the
cull of the country's 17 million
strong mink population last month when a
strain of coronavirus called cluster 5
spread from the animals to humans they
were told to continue
even when it was found that the mutation
had probably died out weeks earlier
and that the government had lacked the
legal authority to order the cult in the
first place
two months ago this farm had more than
25 000 minks
housed in these buildings now like in
more than a thousand
other farms across denmark it's totally
empty
on monday the government finally passed
its order into law and
banned mink farming until december 2021
but andreas and peter hinbot say it's
already too late to save the industry
which until now accounted for 40 of the
world's mink production
denmark's mink was also the most
expensive bringing in an estimated 1
billion dollars a year
i don't see any future farming farming
in denmark
because all the good animals are dead
now of course there are people
saying that it's good for the minks that
we don't have this industry anymore
but what will happen happened is that it
will this industry will move to china
russia where they don't have this
welfare
organization as we have in europe that
already seems to be happening with
chinese mink farmers saying they are
ramping up production
to take advantage of a surge in mink
prices caused by the danish crisis
animal welfare groups don't believe
that's a reason to protect the industry
it means
mains are partners that live completely
alone in nature with a large territory
it's not okay for minks to live in poor
conditions here just because they could
be worse off somewhere else
we don't think there should be minks in
denmark
the crisis that the danes have labelled
the mink saga doesn't end here
some of the animals buried in mass
graves after the cull started
have risen to the surface due to the
effects of decomposition
and authorities fear groundwater and
lakes could have been contaminated by
the rotting bodies
as a commission looks into the handling
of the affair farmers are demanding up
to
four billion dollars in compensation
saying their businesses were buried
along with the minks
paul reese al jazeera jutland denmark